welcome everybody so i'm going to talk
today about
the biden putin summit that took place
yesterday in geneva switzerland we're
going to start with
uh vladimir putin's press conference
momentarily later i want to talk about
donald trump's
analysis if you can use that term which
you really shouldn't
uh trump's analysis on fox news of the
summit and i i
hate that i even have to do this but i
want to just remind everybody
i don't want war with russia the united
states
also does bad things um
etc and every time i talk about this
and i just point out the way i see
vladimir putin and russian government
i get all sorts of emails from people
saying david you're falling for this and
you're falling for that and you should
have this other opinion like this person
or that
i'm not those people so if you want only
to listen to someone with
that opinion go to a different show this
is
my view and my view is not that i want
war with russia
my view is not that putin is uniquely
bad uh
but there are some really interesting
and unique characteristics of how
vladimir putin handle handles himself
with media and how he runs his
government
that i think are worthy of some
discussion so yesterday joe biden and
vladimir putin had a meeting it was more
than three hours long
the american right wing was hoping that
joe biden would embarrass
himself and be unable to speak he'd be
in a fit of acute dementia pooping his
pants or whatever
that didn't happen at the same time
there were some
on the left that often play coy with
putin
who were hoping that biden would be
exposed in this summit
as some kind of neocon warhawk who would
threaten
putin and go completely crazy and that
also didn't happen
and it was mostly unremarkable in that
it was normal diplomacy
with a normal president and a normal
secretary of state
the four years of trump were everything
as power
games and uh uh often just
placating authoritarian leaders around
the world
uh people forgot sort of how diplomacy
works and it's kind of boring
biden goes in with the list of
priorities that he wants to mention and
then the secretary of state and
foreign minister whatever the equivalent
position is called in russia
they have sort of second tier things on
their list that they talk about and it's
a long
and in some colloquial sense boring
process of
diplomacy but the most interesting part
for me
was actually the press conference that
happened after the event
vladimir putin first giving his press
conference later joe biden doing his own
press conference and both taking
questions from the media
i want to focus in on the putin press
conference today because vladimir putin
was actually
very strongly confronted by reporters
but putin is so good at just slipping
around
answering any questions that he ends up
saying
really nothing even when asked directly
about the deaths of his political
opponents
the fact that dissidents end up poisoned
in russia so let's dive right in
here he's asked if he'll stop the cyber
attacks and stop the crackdowns on his
opposition
see if you can find an answer here and
thank you very much for
giving me this question uh first of all
could you characterize the dynamic
between yourself and president biden was
it hostile or was it friendly
and secondly throughout these
conversations did you commit
to ceasing carrying out cyber attacks on
the united states did you commit
to stopping threatening ukraine's
security and did you commit to stop
cracking down on the opposition in
russia
as far as that is concerned i don't
think there was any kind of hostility on
the contrary
our meeting was obviously
a fundamental one many of our joint
positions
are divergent but nevertheless i think
that both sides
manifested determination to
try and understand each other and try
and converge our positions
and i think it was very constructive as
far as
cyber security is concerned we agreed
that we would begin
consultations on that issue and i
believe that's extraordinary
just no answer and and
putin is really amazing at this quite
frankly
asked about the treatment of dissident
alexei navalny putin does two things
that he often does these are classics
from the putin playbook
one putin won't say the guy's name
he'll refer to him as the person you
mentioned or the gentleman you're in
question and he says simply well the guy
was breaking the law
as far as our
non-systematic or non-standard
um opposition is concerned and the
gentleman you quoted
first of all this man knew that he was
breaking the law of russia
he is somebody who has been twice
ignored the requirements of the law
uh the gentleman in question went abroad
for treatment
uh his registration was not uh
the gentleman you referenced this is a
classic putin move
and of course being suspected of
breaking the law
even if true doesn't justify uh in many
countries it doesn't justify or lead to
the treatment that alexei navalny has
received now guys
this doesn't mean the us doesn't do bad
things this doesn't mean the u.s doesn't
have inhumane
jails and prisons but it's just our
analysis of of what it is that is
happening in russia
and how it is that putin responds to
questions about it an
abc reporter is called upon for a
question
and says to putin the list of your
political opponents who are dead
imprisoned or jailed is long
what are you afraid of and putin either
doesn't understand the question or more
likely
putin's a very smart guy putin pretends
not to understand
and successfully avoids actually
answering americans pbc news
american colleagues
mr president thank you so much for
taking my question
uh president biden has said that he
would respond if cyber attacks from
russia
do not stop i'm curious what did he tell
you
did he make any threats and a quick
follow-up if i may sir
uh the list of your political opponents
who are dead
prisoned or jailed is long alexi navalny
this organization calls for free
and fair elections an end to corruption
but russia has
outlawed that organization calling it
extremists and you have now prevented
anyone who supports him to run for
office
so my question is mr president what are
you so afraid of
that should assure us right well once
again
i would like to repeat
uh what i said uh about uh so-called
foreign agents
i've already spoken to your colleagues
now i have to repeat that to you
uh okay once again the u.s has
passed a law which said that
the us would uh particularly favor
individual organizations in russia so it
just goes nowhere
and the reporter points out you didn't
answer the question
what about those dead political
opponents in russia
and putin still will not answer
you didn't answer my question sir if all
of your political opponents
are dead in prison poison
doesn't that send a message that you do
not want a fair political fight
the question of who is murdering whom um
people rioted and went into the congress
in the u.s with political demands
and many people were dictated as
criminals and
they are threatened with imprisonment
from 20 to 25 years
and these people were immediately
arrested after those events he's called
out
and he just brings up the january 6th
trump riots and again for people who say
david you're too aggressive about putin
i'm praising putin
you've really got to hand it to the guy
he doesn't get phased by being called
out
for the political murders that he's
suspected of being involved in
or having ordered last one putin asked
about his relationship with the west
and how russian politics is seen as
unstable
putin answers about everything other
than that take a look at this
bbc news
joe biden
predictable relations but the
west thinks that unpredictability
is a hallmark of russian politics
how do you think you can improve
relations with the west
well i think you've really got to a
high-level art there i envy you
the first part of your question
the west considers and are you going to
reject that
you say
allow me first of all to answer the
first part of your question
you said that in russia uh uh russian
foreign policy
is unpredictable allow me
to respond first of all with
a couple of facts what about the
withdrawal of the us
uh from the uh abm treaty
uh absolutely unpredictable that was so
i'm going to stop it there because it it
just goes nowhere
putin has this ability to talk and talk
and talk and say nothing that is really
stunning
and um it it i i wonder
does he do this with biden in other
words during the summit did the summit
end early maybe
we don't know why it ended early i think
a lot of it was sort of like what else
are we going to talk about
did the summit end early because putin
was doing this stuff it's just an
incredible filibustering and so
really um unsurprising
but amazing how putin is just able to do
this and do this and do this and as a
reminder
i don't want war with russia i don't see
russia as a unique
enemy but i don't play coy with
authoritarian types
and i find nothing progressive in it and
me
as a progressive social democrat uh
i find things to criticize about the
united states
i'm against american imperialism around
the world
on and on and on and also i see very
little that is redeeming
about governments that function the way
that putin's russia functions but i
don't want war with russia
guys don't email me saying i'm uh
suggesting or implying that we need to
attack russia because i'm not
and if you believe that i would
challenge you to find even one instance
of me saying so
one of our sponsors is rise the
science-based app that makes it easy to
improve your sleep and your daily energy
rise helps you figure out what are your
sleep needs helps you achieve your best
possible sleep
through two core principles of sleep
science the idea of sleep debt meaning
how much sleep you owe your body
and circadian rhythms dictating your
energy levels
each morning the rise app tells you how
long you'll be groggy
what your energy peaks will be during
the day when you should start winding
down for bed
for optimal sleep i've been using the
app on my phone every day for a while
now
and i started noticing improved sleep
and energy within just a few nights
and it's giving me a really good
understanding of the relationship
between
my sleep and when i'm sleeping and my
daytime energy
my audience can try rise for free for a
whole week
by going to rise science.com
pacman the link is underneath this video